like I said going to give you mechanics
dynamics and all that kind of thing from
a non physics point of view okay so
therefore I assume you don't know what
it forces right maybe you something
heard the word sort of bands around but
in our mathematical modeling of motion
has a very specific meaning okay now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
and avoid some of the nuance and that
kind of thing and give you a succinct
definition as I can for each of the
different things including for Newton's
laws okay I might miss some tiny little
minor details here and there but I want
you to capture the sense of it cuz
that's the most important part to equip
you to do the mathematics okay so this
is this way I can describe forces that
cause acceleration if there's something
in the world and you can cause
acceleration then I call it a force
right now remember acceleration for us
has a very specific meaning
mathematically what does it mean what
we've been thinking about measure
thanks a lot give me a detail but what
does it mean thank you it's a change in
velocity right so what you're getting is
something which causes acceleration and
acceleration causes a change in velocity
now I want you to remember change in
velocity doesn't necessarily mean you're
just getting faster you can get slower
as well that's still a change in
velocity you could be going at 50 meters
per second and then still be going at 50
meters per second but if the direction
of that 50 meters per second changes
then there's a change in velocity right
because remember velocity includes
direction unlike speed so anything that
causes this caused a change in velocity
which therefore indicates like when you
are all right now pretty much you're all
still right so there's no acceleration
on you your velocity is not changing but
there are forces acting on
Yeah right I can think of two primary
ones each of which is counteracting the
other what are the two forces continued
right okay so you've got gravity pulling
you toward the center of the earth okay
but you're not moving and the reason why
is because there's another opposite
force right you've got the normal force
because it's coming from the ground
perpendicular to the ground you can
describe it really as it's actually the
electromagnetic force isn't it because
there's the electrons in your feet and
the electrons in the ground and they
really according to the Pauli exclusion
principle hate each other's guts so they
weren't they refused to be in the same
spot so that's why they're seven okay
so underneath here this is really really
important idea and the force of zero so
I really like this phrase it's called
the resultant supports because it's it's
the force that results after you add
everything together if you've got a net
force of zero then there's no
acceleration but of course you could
have forces acting in all kinds of
different directions so long as they
balance out right balanced forces yes
zero that means no change of masseuses
something is still right so before we
are move off of this is start talking
about the laws I just want to think
about some like typical forces that you
encounter we've already named a couple
of them so we say normal force remember
anything like normals attention and
normally turning that direction
where is which way is it facing okay but
different kinds of like what is it that
is the answer if the electromagnetic
force electromagnetic right so I'm just
pretty together it's that the electrons
are doing anything right and you guys
know the electromagnet is one force
you've heard that means like very very
early science what other kinds of forces
speak now just normal experience can
cause acceleration okay okay
I'll come back to that one in a second
I'll come back to it I'm tracking is
like causes like overall typing so let
me give you an example
how about friction friction friction
exerts forces on objects because it
causes them generally it causes a change
in velocity to be opposite to whichever
direction the velocity years yeah so
it's flowing you know so air resistance
is kind of like a hot it's a kind of
friction a few other ones two other main
ones that you're going to learn that
you're going to experience really when
we talk about air resistance or like
water or whatever that's really a medium
when you're passing through
okay now I'm distinguishing that from
like remember I said this is kind of
like oh these are kind of related
together I can talk about like the
friction between my feet and the ground
when I'm running okay but that's not the
medium I'm running from running through
air yeah so these are actually two
different things so I'm gonna
distinguish between them and this is
we'll get to this and the resistive
issue there's one more really important
category on the way you're talking about
and I'll I'll take him wraps example no
don't use this just yet if you go
something and it's spinning around okay
like on the end of string okay or like
yeah okay
there you go right um what is it for
example like you guys can see on the end
see how this those DNA strands on the
end of those
okay can you see them okay so they're on
there what is holding them to the fan
okay
now the sticky tape is okay I thought
that it's done you're feeling very
sleepy
this is wholly odd because it has what
we call tension okay so there is tension
in that tape there's tension in the
blades of the of the fan there's tension
in like this is what's holding these
things together and stop you from just
flight now this is obviously not an
exhaustive list but these are the ones
you're going to encounter most
frequently this is just kind of assumed
we just kind of assume the objects that
posture each other by them it's an
important thing for you guys to
recognize that's a story one okay right
so these are what forces are and these
are some examples let's talk about
Newton's laws now and there are three of
them
now I can't remember I said to you I'm
going to try and give everything in a
succinct perform as possible sometimes
that means the grammar is slightly
awkward but I've tried to pack more
meaning into unless words so you have
less to remember because there's a lot
of things to remember you so the first
law is a so I'm gonna come back to this
idea of when you've got a net force of 0
and then force of zero results in and
this this sort of comes out of the
definition of what a force is right if
you observe a net force then what you
have because your velocity isn't
changing that means your velocities
twisting let me say that again right a
force by definition is something that
causes acceleration causes a change in
velocity but if you don't have any net
force then there is no change in
velocity so it's constant okay now
people who do physics here you can help
me out the proper full statement of
Newton's first law it actually means the
two kinds the two instances of constant
velocity that there are can you tell me
what they are
yes okay very good so if you've got an
object and it's at rest okay for what
study zero then plus velocity means it's
still at zero okay so that's fair enough
so stationary is one kind of custom for
today but there is of course another
kind which is I'm going to be a little
more fine here and again I'm going to
try to pack more meaning into less words
the alternative is uniform straight-line
version okay now back that every phrase
has meaning
uniform as in not speeding up not
slowing down them and of course it has
to be this straight line so if you've
got an object and it's orbiting around
the planet right if I have a uniform
like it's not getting fast or getting
slowed up because it is orbiting after
all but it's not in a straight line
it's constantly turning right it turned
around and ran around so that's not that
constant velocity right the speed might
not be changing but the direction is
changing your time now why is that what
is making its direction and therefore
its falsity constantly change what's the
answer
it's it's gravity right gravity is
what's pulling it away if if you had an
object Albany around right and suddenly
the planet just cease to exist just
disappear what's gonna happen our object
it's going to fly off in a uniform
straight why does that make sense yeah I
wouldn't do to keep down it to them
because we for the mathematic questions
you don't worry about them okay so I
just I'm just conveying to you enough
for the physics to do the mathematical
part that make sense
and so yes so this this this tendency of
objects and we're going to have
particles bodies things with mass but we
don't worry about their mother having
the tendency to resist acceleration that
tendency to remain it close to Boston we
call this initial right so the first law
is all that